foreign
[Music]
[Applause]
hello hello
good evening I'm Michael Shore and today
I have the pleasure of chatting with one
of my very best friends
I don't get to see him often he's mostly
off in New York focused on the insanity
of Washington DC so when he is here it
is a real treat he is quite simply one
of the most intelligent and talented
people I know
and despite his celebrity he is still
the same guy I met almost 25 years ago
blustery
painfully ill-informed
very sweaty
desperate for his dad's approval and
every time he's on TV he looks like he's
coked out of his mind
his most recent book the un united
states of woke America how liberals got
triggered by my big strong dad was named
one of the quote most unintentionally
I am so sorry
I'm doing an event for Donald Trump Jr
right after this
and I think
sorry Start over start over good evening
I'm Michael Shore and today I have the
pleasure of chatting with one of my very
best friends
I don't get to see him often he's mostly
in New York focused on the insanity of
Washington D.C
so when he is here it's a real treat
it's weirdly similar
you and Don Jr
for the last two decades Seth Meyers has
been appearing on your TVs first on SNL
and then for nine years this host of
late night explaining what is happening
in the world why it's funny why it's
enraging and then subtly prescribing a
remedy for what ails us late night
comedians at heart are public servants
and although I'm biased I believe this
man is one of the very best and most
dedicated that we've ever had please
welcome the second most intelligent and
talented person I know Seth Meyers
I always thought it was so weird that
you were friends with both of us
like we're I feel like we're so
different but here's the thing you guys
don't know Don Jr the way I know Don Jr
hi buddy hi everybody thank you so much
for being here
[Applause]
yes thank you so I want to start by
talking about the medium of late night
television in general uh like capital L
capital N late night because you and I
both started in late night we met at
Saturday Night Live in 2001.
um so let's talk about how it's evolved
we're roughly the same age you're in
your mid-40s I'm in my late 70s but
when we were kids here's what late night
was to me late night was Johnny Carson
uh ambling on stage telling a couple
very gentle jokes about Ronald Reagan
swinging a golf club and then chatting
amicably with like Buddy Hackett I I
feel like late night was a lean back
medium people were in bed half asleep
and they lean back and then what has
happened in the time that you and I have
been working in that field you more than
me is it became a lean forward business
it started I think with the sort of John
Stuart Daily Show in Colbert and then
you and and Tina and Amy on on update it
became a thing where people had to lean
forward and engage like is that your
general scent am I right is my theory
right I think your theory is Right
weirdly it took me a while to even find
it during my show having done update and
having leaned forward in that because I
think I still remember that old era we
were watching growing up and I thought
this is going to be a little bit more
laid back and then you know events
conspired to make it I think an
impossible time to live through being
chill right and so the big question to
me is how much of this is 2016. really I
think well I think a lot of it was that
with that said in around 2015 we that
was the when we first started doing a
closer look and we wouldn't do it as
often as we do now now we do it three
times a week and in the beginning it was
maybe once a month and then it was twice
a month but even then when we did a long
form thing about say Planned Parenthood
hearings or about the Greek debt crisis
it was amazing how people would say oh I
really like that thing you did whereas
the things we were doing that could have
been any era of late night what we would
call a desk piece you know where you
know famous first drafts where you talk
what was the original first line of uh
Tale of Two Cities which really could
have been Jack Parr could have done it
you know
um those no one ever talked to us about
we're in a contest right now to see who
can make the oldest latency I went buddy
Carson nice try
I don't know who's before Jack Parr who
could we I think that might it might be
hard to beat yeah Steve Allen there you
go that that person won yep
the teenager in the front row
so by the way when I started working at
Saturday Night Live my grandmother rest
her soul stayed up super late to watch
the show and uh and I said Kiki uh how
did did you like the show how was it and
she paused for a long time and then she
said you know who was funny with Steve
Allen and it was the it was the she was
too nice to say like I hated that so she
said she said she was a funny person
yeah at one point a funny person it's
interesting that she took the thing if
you can't say anything nice don't say
anything at all and she was like I'll
just say something nice about a
different thing
it's a corollary to the rule it just
prays something distract you with those
good something talk about some over here
uh so but even from the beginning in
your show so you abandoned what I think
of as the signature element of late
night television which is the standing
monologue yeah a person comes out at 11
30 or 12 30 stands in front of a weird
curtain or a weird backdrop and tells 8
to 12 jokes about what happened in the
news and then says we got a great show
and goes over and sits down yeah you
abandoned that and I remember you told
me a funny story about Lauren Michael
yes that that sort of pinpointed
everything that is amazing and also
irritating about him yes it's funny that
you said it's funny because it's also
deeply heartbreaking which is
when I got the show Lauren who speaks in
riddles said
first of all when Lauren I don't know if
I ever told you when people said how did
you find out you got late night Lauren
called me
and you will know this to be true every
conversation you have with Lauren it
feels like he's doing a follow-up to a
conversation that didn't happen
so he doesn't lay down any like base
coat he just goes you know I think
you'll do it it'll be good and I'm like
wait are you giving me late night
because
I'm going to want to remember this call
forever and it stinks the way you're
doing these things but uh so Lauren gave
me the job he goes you know it'll take
you 18 months to figure it out and I
very at the time I'd been working at SNL
for a long time I felt uh that I was
really good at figuring things out and I
remember internally saying it's not
going to take me 18 months and then I
did the show for 18 months doing a
standing monologue where I never knew
what to do with my hands and it was
super awkward and nobody liked it and
then I was like why don't I just start
at the desk and I I remember doing it
and then doing the math and realizing
how long it had been I was like fucking
18 months
Point Michaels
he has a lot of aphorisms and and little
lessons uh that he tells everybody and
one of them was if you ever the cameras
ever pointed at the at someone's feet
and you can see the floor he he always
goes don't shoot the floor we don't want
to see the floor and it's like he does
it so often that you're just like all
right right and uh of 18 years later I
was making a pilot and I was like this
this scene like lacks energy what is
wrong with it and I was like ah it
starts on the floor like he was right
these things come back to you like it
turns out he knows what he's talking
about when it comes to television
production well it is that he's had a
hundred thousand hours yeah you know
what I mean yeah he's 10 Malcolm
Gladwell Geniuses and one guy
it's three Geniuses with a giant trench
coat on pretending to be one genius a
beautiful Italian trench coat so well
Taylor a black product yeah yeah
gorgeous
um so a lot of late night in general and
I think your show specifically is best
when it kind of goes off the rails or
things that are unexpected happen so we
have a clip from your signature segment
uh a closer look let's see if we can
roll that clip
hey you guys want to hear the funniest
thing I've ever heard wrong clip wrong
clip
that well we'll come later we'll see
that clip a good nice little taste
I have that here hey um
wrong clip
remember this this is the presidential
records Act
I have the right to take stuff Hannity
Hannity even tries to move on and Trump
is like no wait I'm not done confessing
Sean I have the right
I have the right to take stuff be a
classified documents or candy bars in
the checkout that I hired and what I
call my shoplifting code all right all
right let's move on Mr President before
we do Sean zagnet it's a little melted
but it's still very delicious
crunchy peanut butter
crunchy peanut butter with coconut for
we love his act not everybody it's very
it's a very modern candy bar and when
Seth brought it up today and the Young
Writers they said no one's going to know
zagna they're not going to know him and
so I said everybody knows that not you
wait when they when we say Zach now
there's going to be a big cheer from the
audience
and now said
and now and I'll tell you what's
happening right now Seth seeing the
silhouette of his writers and they're
celebrating how wrong he was and it's
very it's very hurtful that they were
very very cruel that they do that
laughs
there's nothing better
part of part of the Great tradition of
late night comedy is anarchy right it's
just like no it you have the sense that
no one is minding the story no one's
watching no one's standing over you
there's no network people like wagging
their finger and when things I think the
difference is like it's when things
genuinely go Haywire like that like yeah
when you everyone's on the same on the
same wavelength and it's it organically
kind of losing spiraling out it also a
couple things make a moment like that
also feel earned for us and I think for
the audience as well which is we went
through this crazy time where we were
doing the show in an attic and then in
an empty studio and so we just used to
take these crazy tangents that made us
laugh because there was no audience to
say what the fuck are you doing and then
because they were the people that it was
our audience so they were watching it
and understand why we're doing it so now
we come back and when something goes
wrong like that and I will say so sell
Gentile who writes closer look he does
sit in
line and it's crazy he had said don't do
zagnet and I did zagnet and it's like a
muppet reaction like because I can't
really see him but I see a silhouette go
like
and he did that and so then I was like
well if I I'm just gonna just go on this
and I think that it's nice because you
know the longer you do the show the more
I think the audience knows that we are a
friendly loving group of a staff that
can bust on each other like that and of
course it's really fun when you just
admit that you as the host were really
wrong yeah that it brings up another
Point by the way which is you are great
to your writers as a writer I thank you
for this you have Amber and Jenny on all
the time
um
that is a that was my favorite thing
about Conan's Show when he was in the 12
30 slot was we knew all those writers
all the SNL writers knew all the Conan
writers and every time John Glazer or uh
any of those Ding Dongs was on camera it
felt like a win for writers and I feel
like it gives the show this sense of
like Europe unit you're like a family
you're like a fighting force that that
like each other and now the Amber and
Jenny section joke Seth can't tell my
personal favorite segment on the show
like now it's just you three just
giggling the entire time yeah and then
the fun thing and the fun thing about
that and the fun thing about jokes Seth
can't tell is I think when we first
started doing it even though it feels
this foolproof way to tell dangerous
jokes because we're admitting this is a
bad idea
and yet you would still have that moment
of oh I would say I think this is going
to get too big a ground and Amber and
Jenny their credit were always like it
doesn't matter like that's and now we've
done it long enough that it is just
giggling fun because we're like living
out the conversation we had earlier
about these jokes and again I think um
the audience uh knows that
um Henry Winkler who's the nicest man in
Show Business
um who also loves that segment and the
first time he was on the show and he saw
uh uh amber and Jenny backstage he was
so excited he went black lady lesbian
and they were saying it was like it was
so uh it was so loving and pure that any
other time in their lives if it had
happened it would be like what oh no I
have to get out of here white and heard
it and like wanted to cry and gave him a
hug and took a picture that's fantastic
uh let's talk about impressions for a
second oh yeah so there's your Trump
which I think has gotten very good thank
you if I'm not gonna say the SNL
audition the famously harrowing SNL
audition requires when you did it two or
three three I did three so I remember
Hugh Grant yep I was a good Hugh Grant
it was a pretty good Hugh Grant we have
a similar face that helps all right
there was just a lot of frumping and
yeah yeah
but I I could not remember the other two
uh David Arquette
oh Dave this is 2001. he was doing a lot
of those collect call commercials
do you remember no it was back when
there were commercials about making
collect calls
and then
I did Russell Crowe
hosting a talk show
and so is Russell Crowe telling bad
jokes that would bomb and then I would
go are you not entertained
and then you might not remember I tried
to write it as a sketch I don't remember
Russell Crowe talk show and uh uh Mike
Shoemaker our dear friend producer of my
show and a real straight talker said uh
here's why this is never gonna work it
went to dress it didn't work here's why
it's never gonna work he goes uh one of
your heads is two of his
and he's like there's no makeup or
anything you can ever do where you will
walk out and the audience will go oh
Russell Crowe right he's like your neck
looks like uh like he has you there
would be five of your necks in his like
big strong neck yeah
um Seth uh does a segment on the show
you haven't done in a while called
Second Chance Theater yeah yeah oh and
some Second Chance Theater fans yeah by
the way just you saying we've now
mentioned Jack Parr Steve Allen and
Buddy Hackett and then you told the
story that involved a person doing a
commercial about a collect call yeah
this is like a time capsule that we're
in right now this is that's actually if
you recorded this they wouldn't Tick
Tock wouldn't put it on but the
algorithm would just shut it down not
for kids
uh so Second Chance Theater was a is a
segment on the show that I don't think
you've done in a while at least I
haven't seen it no yeah during the yeah
because I don't think we've done a post
the pandemic yet it was uh a situation
which when someone who worked on SNL
came on the show as a guest they could
bring a sketch that had that they'd try
to get on SNL and it had never gotten on
and they would Mount the sketch yes and
this was my my favorite thing in the
world uh because when you work at SNL
there are certain sketches that the
writers love and and talk about all the
time even not because they're
necessarily good just because they're
like famously weird or funny and yeah
you actually gave so Will Forte did it
today just did it Sandberg did it
Samberg did it right and it yeah it
isn't just a bad sketch it has to be
something it had to have bombed in a way
that you as writers still talk about it
yeah yeah so like Forte did one called
genjuman Franklin where he was although
the core of the joke is easy a woman who
looks exactly like Benjamin Franklin
right
that's pretty much the whole that's the
whole thing yeah and sadakis is super
thinks it's super hot right
um
uh Sedaka said a wonderful like
incredibly like oscar-winning acting
performance in a sketch called juggling
classes where it was he was a he had a
shirt said ask me about juggling classes
and there was one of those um you know
where you take and pull that thing off
and he went into a coffee shop and he
just basically gave a long speech about
how nobody had taken nobody wanted to
learn juggling it was basically like an
eight minute monologue and then
Andes which was I think my favorite
because how dumb it was and it was based
on a thing Andy used to do when we
worked at SNL is he was a guy at a like
work party who was like Hey I'm gonna go
to the bathroom you guys want to come
with and it was just
it was a guy who just didn't want to go
to the bathroom alone
and also in the most sambergian way he
he also because they're like I'm gonna
hit the head and that's just like you
know what I mean like just like turn
like slang about bathrooms that nobody's
used forever and he used to do in real
life he used to come
um remember his first year on SNL he
would come open my door like Tuesday
night we'd be riding all night and he
would open the door and be like hey I'm
gonna go to the bathroom you want to
come with I'd be like no I don't want to
come with I'd be like pretty long walk
I'd love the company I'm like I'm not
going with
and I go get out of here and I don't
remember my office it had that front it
had like a frosted glass door so he
would close it and then just stand there
and you would see just like and at the
time you had you know you'd like that
Muppet hair and so just like his
silhouette and he would just breathe
like this
so he's so irritated
uh the best um getting back to
impressions for one second I have a
theory and I want to run it by you
publicize it and see if it worked if
it's real
one of your most common and I think best
and most beloved Impressions currently
is Mike Lindell the more pillow my
pillow guy yeah Mike Lindell is a
somewhat barrel-chested gentleman yeah
with a big bushy mustache he's from
Minnesota yeah could be from Pittsburgh
could be yeah my theory is
he's an evil version of your dad yeah
very much
everything is that what you're tapping
into because then when I watch you do it
I'm like this is you in a in an
alternate universe doing interpretation
of your human father yeah and I think
the interesting thing is Mike Lindell is
an evil person who's like very jovial
and my dad is a lovely person who's very
uh Angry
you know because that's the thing about
Mike Lindell this so he's so mad that
the election got stolen but the way he
talks about he's so he's just like
everything it's like excited about how
we can fix it he talks about it the way
you would if you saw like a monkey
riding a horse
like that's how he like runs in to say
the machine's got out yeah I saw him
like uh all right let's talk about your
interviews when you got this job knowing
you pretty well I think I may have said
this to you but I I my instant thought
was that the interviews will be where
you shine because your incredible
conversationalist you tell great stories
and also as has been proven uh you're
you're very quick I think it's your
improv background but also you don't
need notes and I this is a subtle thing
for you true late night aficionados you
you may remember this from past shows
you know you're Jack Parr is your Steve
Allen's uh
the most awkward part of most late night
shows to me is the the guest comes out
and the host has a blue card that
they're holding like low but you can
still see it you're not fooling anybody
and they say something like so how was
your flight in was the flight very bumpy
do you have a problem flying when
there's turbulence and then amazingly
the person's like I do yes I get very
scared in fact a funny story happened to
me whatever and it's just this like very
bullet pointed like they went through an
interview they wrote down and the host's
only job is to kind of cue the five
stories they're gonna tell you don't do
that and I think it's to your great
credit that you don't do that so let's
look at this clip of you and Jeff
Goldblum Jeff Goldblum not the other one
and and you'll see what I mean
yeah so that to that to you teach me let
me learn from you okay wow that's a line
from a movie what movie is it from teach
me let me learn from you teach me let me
learn from you Lolita no okay
but that was an impulsive and impulsive
yeah
I love Lolita you like that you like
that Nabokov book of course and the
first Lolita or the second which do you
like do you make with uh I feel like
we're in Dangerous Ground when you're
like
in any case we're we we uh I dropped
mental breadcrumbs what we were talking
about is a quote from the movie what
movie what movie teach me teach me let
me learn from you wait Fred do you have
any guesses I don't you don't know okay
I'm gonna give you a clue uh it was
spoken by Robert De Niro oh teach me let
me learn from you by Robert De Niro
teach me let me learn I what what I
could tell you to whom he said it in the
movie I could tell you who directed them
okay but just know this is we're no
longer talking about you at this point I
want okay I do appreciate as a guest
that you fully don't care that you've
just started playing I don't care movie
trivia
I'm of very little interested in myself
really it turns out teach me let me
learn from you yeah animated
name one animated movie that Robert De
Niro has done oh you know what he was in
that Bullwinkle movie but he was not it
was live action so yes oh yeah the shark
movie there's Wally over there jumping
in oh really thank you Wally all right
I'm not familiar with that no so I could
Jeff or I could tell you who's I'm
choking or I could oh what's happening I
don't have to have a lozenge in your
mouth
somebody said I was obliged to do that
who oh right we that is a new thing
we're doing with our guests
Seth likes
they said Seth likes everyone to be did
it look like somebody who worked on the
show that said put a lozenge in right
now
here's a good game next time I stick my
tongue out will I have something on it
or not okay
that was that's from Lolita that game no
it's not but you have you have to play
yes or no okay yes or no yes
all right who did Robert De Niro say
that line to his character's name this
will give it away is Rupert Popkin oh
okay so you go king of comedy yeah and
he set it to um to uh Sandra bernheim
well there you go teach me let me learn
from you okay well here we are and um
we're obviously running out of time but
no um
we do um luckily we have you here I get
to talk to you for a little bit longer
after the commercial break but I want to
ask a question I have another couple
ideas by the way I want to hear your
question don't try just like give
yourself a moment to finish the lozenge
two ideas your hair reminds me of Clint
Eastwood in what movie
oh uh uh Play Misty For Me No Okay
um it's younger Dirty Harry no okay what
that could be Paint Your Wagon Paint
Your Wagon all right Lee Marvin with Lee
Marvin yeah
Now isn't that more interesting than a
story about a person who barfed in a on
a plane ride or something I mean look
sometimes you gotta it's a little bit
like being at the poker table when you
get pocket aces you know I I you just
Jeff Goldman you gotta play the hand
you're dealt and that was so much fun
okay you're being modest but the point
is is that when you interview people you
are just looking at them and having a
conversation with them and I that is
it's shocking to say this that's
essentially unique among late night
hosts I think I the only thing I knew
about interviewing people the only thing
I thought I could bring to it as a skill
was being an improviser and knowing that
the most important thing in improv is
listening and so that I mean it's a very
flattering clip it's fun to watch but it
was it because it is like two people are
actually listening to each other we're
both talking very fast but everything
that's paying off is because we're
calling back together you're actually
connected there is a moment uh Seth's
old friends as am I with Ike baronholzi
actor and right her and Ike was one of
the first guests on your show a long
time ago and in the interview somehow
they got into the and they used to do
improv together and some of they got on
the subject of James Bond do you
remember this moment and Ike started was
like being like blustery and was like
who do who would I be if I were James
Bond who would I be would I be Daniel
Craig or Sean Connery and Seth
immediately said you're both of them
stuffed into the same suit
and it felt like and this is a weird
this is a unique thing I can say is it
felt like I was in a room with the two
of you when you were talking to each
other yeah I also really want to stress
I wouldn't have said that to a guest
that I had known I'd known like for 20
years an old friend yes right
um what can I say one thing that wasn't
in the clip this is a thing that uh Jeff
Goldblum did later in that interview I
want you I've seen you be me and point
your finger like that okay
like he did it so fast I couldn't
it's like his whole life he was like
anytime somebody does this I'm gonna do
that yeah you start you started doing
that in 1979.
I realize it's harder to do like I
bumped right into your finger his was
like seamless yeah yeah that's why he's
pretty yeah he's really good at it yeah
uh another thing I love about your show
is the from the beginning the guests you
book are really interesting you have
artists and novelists and comic book uh
people on the show was that the design
for was that the thing you wanted from
the beginning yeah it was funny because
I think we wanted this wide breath and
we would say in early interviews we want
politicians and athletes and and artists
and authors and the reality is we found
out pretty early politicians are
terrible guests uh that is a
non-partisan observation it doesn't
matter it's not about what kind of
politicians you are they're just very
talking pointy yeah they're very talk
every now and then you get a wild card
and it's great but the reality is
they're talking pointy and they will
more often than not answer the question
they wanted you to ask like it doesn't
matter what you guys say like I'm gonna
do this thing they just pivot yeah and
if you don't stop them they'll do
they'll give the same answer twice like
it's like one of those like uh Marriott
videos where person just if you keep
watching it's the channel on the hotel
channel that just gives you that yeah
and then uh and then athletes retired
athletes are great yeah but like I think
today's modern athletes are like a
pretty like um they're just like safe
yeah in a way that's very wise because
of uh yeah they're well they're guarding
a like billion dollar breaks which was
not the way like when you watch like Bob
Euchre on Carson that's not what he was
doing now we got Carson again yeah and
Euchre
um but uh but authors are great and it's
so funny because people know them the
least very often yeah subject with an
author is like how do like what's your
writing process yeah I think what's your
writing process and since you don't you
can't talk about a story too much but
you know how did you want to write about
this like how much you know because I
and I I it's interesting because a lot
of most of our authors and I think most
authors in general have at some point
taught if they're not actively teaching
right now and so they're very
comfortable in front of people and
they're really good and precise at
giving answers right which is the other
thing that is uh harder to do as a talk
show guest than I think a lot of people
give credit to I I I've been on Seth's
show uh twice as a guest very kindly had
me on and um the first time I went on I
was the third guest and the or the
second guest I guess and the first guest
was kellyanne Conway
and it was the day that the story of the
the Russian PB tape
uh and so like it was insane because it
came up to me was like how are you doing
I have to go tell Kelly and Conway that
this thing just came out and then she
has to call the president of the United
States to ask what she should do and
that's what happened yeah we it broke at
say four I was in the cab on the way to
30 Rock yeah and we I we printed it off
like the CNN story and just out of
courtesy right like we did not there was
no interest in having a gotcha question
but it was hey I we just want to make
sure you saw this because I'm going to
want to ask about it it was like
I'm gonna need a moment
turns out when you work for Donald Trump
it's very hard to throw you
I mean I again one of the wonderful
things about late night especially a
show that is on daily we had this
problem so when I was at SNL I uh
produced bacon update for the for three
years it was the first three years you
were there and we had this problem which
was there were The Daily Show was on
other shows were on every day so every
day whatever the big story was they were
doing jokes about that thing and we
would get to Saturday and we would have
to throw out six or eight jokes because
uh Leno did this or Letterman did this
or whatever
and the ex the the flip side of that is
when you were doing a show every day
insane things happen in this country
every single day so to what extent are
you and the writers on a daily basis
scrambling because something comes out
like late in the day that does that
demands that you address it
um less since uh 2020 and I don't know
why yeah weird
um just like weirdly happened that
things got Chiller but um
we the nice thing we realized was if
something broke too late to be able to
actually like
frame fit it into the thesis statement
of that night's closer look we realized
our audience was willing to wait they'd
rather us wait and and give it proper
context than just shove it in with the
monologue however we will scramble we'll
sort of send out the alert it would be
great to have a joke off the top about
this because those sort of Standalone
and right so those are those are the
easier scrambles the crazy thing
I believe for example during the Trump
Administration I think we did a closer
look on Michael Flynn that we filmed at
six in the afternoon and by the time it
aired he'd been fired so that
that hasn't been a problem recently
again since you would say roughly 2020.
I can't put it like a day on it but it
was definitely somewhere it was like I
know that like it was like January 6 was
definitely the last one where it was
like crazy
and then by like January 7th it sort of
chilled out yeah so the the trajectory
starting on January 7th was towards yeah
whereas January 6th we were like I don't
know what's gonna happen here j36 was
the uh I'm uh it's that one uh I know
there's a January 6 every year but I'm
talking about that the one the famous
One the best with the one now that's
gonna be I mean I think the all Adam I
hate to say this to all future January 6
but
um but that was the one day where we
actually we went live because we had
we're ready to go and we were watching
it and realized oh no it's so dangerous
right now to have any final thoughts
yeah on what's happening right or even
any intermediate thoughts yeah yeah it
was because it really felt like
the tone of what this country is going
through could massively change in the
next six hours yeah and so by the time
sorry to get deep into the weeds here
but by the time you went live had they
had gotten back together and certified
the election yes so it was you know very
fortunately it was but it and I will say
um and he does such an incredible job
with a closer look but Sal wrote this
opening monologue that has aged I
believe incredibly well where it was it
was a very like sobering like let's
never forget what happened today right
and uh it's one of those days where you
feel like incredibly lucky to work with
somebody who can in those moments where
we're all just like freaking out be like
I'm gonna go write something right now
and I think that that's man oh man yeah
that's some Aaron Sorkin shit right
there oh he's a yeah oh he are Sorkin
uh from going transitioning from
something incredibly important to
something that couldn't be less
important thank you let's talk about
corrections oh my God I'd love to talk
about
my people
every Thursday right yep every audience
goes home yeah and then you
like a lunatic stay in the studio
you have read a bunch of YouTube
comments I've read all these all of them
yeah by yourself no one helps you nobody
helps me and then you know what the
hardest part is Mike scrolling
like sometimes it's 3 000 comments under
YouTube and you just like the hardest
part is just scrolling till all the
comments are open you don't you don't
have to do this yeah okay keep going
so uh Mike Shoemaker your producer said
that Thursday this is a quote Thursday
is the one day of the week where we
don't talk because Seth's mind is
spinning with corrections yeah
yeah I leave the floor to you to explain
this this insane thing that you do it's
I love it so much by the way it's clear
you do too and you would love it and
you're a little jealous you didn't think
of it yeah that's accurate this is so up
your ass it really is yeah
I'm acting all high in my deal but I'm
hoping that you invite me literally
inside joke minutia it started the
origin story is I said Legos and these
Lego uh enthusiasts Nazis
um
said it's not Lego Legos it's Lego
bricks right
and so I basically spent a week trying
to apologize and make a correction every
night you did an apology and then you
got something else right like I said
Lego blocks and they're like bricks and
so I kept digging a deeper hole and then
I said to Shoemaker I want to do on
Thursday we'll just put it on YouTube I
don't want to tell anybody what I'm
gonna do I'm just going to address some
things at the desk and it was three
minutes it was super fun and it also
reminded me of the year we were doing
shows in the studio with no audience
where I was just playing for crew laughs
right which was a really fun time I mean
not a fun time
um
yeah
that's the that's the pull quote that
comes out of this yeah covid was great
was very good for me
um
uh but yeah we and then so I started
doing it
and it just kept getting longer and now
it's a real it's it's easy 15 minutes a
week well you also did a 50th
Anniversary show uh yeah 50th episode
spectacular yeah we refer so I have a
question I refer to the people who leave
these negative YouTube comments as
jackals they're the correction jackals
right somebody asked me today if I just
watch corrections but I haven't
commented am I a jackal too and that
might be addressed in the next correct
it should be noted that now I read all
the YouTube comments but mostly I'm
addressing comments that were left on
previous Corrections so this is just it
it's become this yeah you're doomed this
is dude it's gonna assume you it's so
and it's funny because we sometimes will
try to pick an episode the best like
represents corrections but every
Corrections it is this funny thing
because I think we've done 75 and people
say which one should they do and I'm
like you gotta start from the beginning
um but it is um it's really fun and it
also is uh
it's I get so nervous I that's in a
really exciting way it feels like I'm
about to go do a
Open Mic Stand Up set where the topic is
the shows we did last week I'm like
doing stand-up about a showing and you
actually are nervous I actually get
because there's no I haven't run it by
anybody and like sometimes it's and
again I'm doing it for the the crew I'm
like doing it for the people I see every
day like it's not an anonymous audience
and when it's when it goes well it's the
moment name some of these celebrities
that you got to send in videos and take
part in the specs the spectacular uh uh
Ben and Jerry who I'm very mad at
because they won't give me my own late
night flavor right
um
uh Chris Angel Mind Freak yeah
Nathan Lane sure yeah Christine baransky
right Harvey feierstein right they're
the cast of my Broadway musical cicada
sagada
thank you no um how many of these people
knew what the hell it was oh nobody oh
Werner Herzog
I verder hurts I was on my show and I
said uh hey I it was I mean again I was
so psyched so psyched to meet him right
sure and then I was like I think there's
only all right he was in parks and rec
he was which by the way I kept in the
back of my mind I'm like he said yes to
Parkside so I said hey um can I film you
real quick saying hey jackals like
and he was like what do you want me to
say and I'm like just do this and he's
like okay and he did it
very brief story uh we had an episode of
Parks and Rec
um where uh Chris Pratt and aubry's
characters Andy in April bought a really
disgusting spooky awful rundown house
um that they loved because it was so
disgusting and we were like who should
be the owner of the house and someone
was like Vern or Herzog and I was like
that's correct that is who should own
the house so we reached out to him and
we were like dude can you do this and he
rewrote all these weird lines for him
being Werner herzogi about how that it
it was like and there isn't used to be
an abandoned doll factory nearby and
this is where they this house is where
they house the people who worked there
and went insane they lived in his house
and um so anyway he was on the show and
he was hilarious and uh Aubry Plaza who
at the time was maybe 25 years old or 26
years old
um went up to him and said do you
believe in ghosts and he was like what
are you asking me and she was like do
you believe in ghosts and got really
intense and he was like I don't want to
talk about this and she was like just
tell me if you believe in ghosts and
followed him around the house asking if
he believes in ghosts and then so we
shot it it was great and then we had an
idea later in the season for him to come
back and we we called him again and said
like would you like to come back and do
another episode and he went no that lady
scared me
hahaha
I love it a guy like like I'll shoot in
a jungle for 18 months
but I can't do that
twice Listen to Like a Man audio of a
man being eaten by a bear yeah and be
fine with it
it's really good Aubry no thank you
um let's talk about day drinking great
another excellent segment let's so let's
first let's watch the clip the that you
got a little preview of here's you and
lizzo uh day drinking
we talked about how much Shoemaker nope
likes the green ones
hey you guys want to hear the funniest
thing I've ever heard one of our writers
came over and had his mask on and lizzo
said to him are you Paul Rudd hey come
over here yes there's the Ant-Man you
guys know Ant-Man Paul run no
you guys looking now get out of here get
out of here that's not Paul Ryan no he
would do that let me see the rest of his
face you want to see the rest of his
face at the end no no not now we're
gonna save it for the end yeah yeah
here's what's gonna happen when we're
done day drinking he's gonna pull it
down and we're gonna have a close-up on
you
[Music]
and we're gonna see her reaction to how
much
Paul Rudd not Paul Rudd looks like Paul
Ryan I want to ask about something right
around Christmas we do this thing called
day drinking on the show and I was doing
it with lizzo and uh your name came up I
saw it yeah all right and again uh you
it must have been very exciting because
Liz oh let me tell you one of the most
Charming human beings I don't know if
you've been lucky enough to meet her
I've never met her I watched I mean I
watched it was on the show and when I
heard lizzo say my name I was like no I
was like yeah I got all excited and it's
by the way it's a weird thing when
you're not expecting to hear that yeah
and that segment was hilarious by the
way that whole every time you do it it's
so funny she really did sort of raise
the bar I I keep telling people she's so
deeply funny
in even well with like inebriated she
like talks like a comedy writer so funny
so Charming
um it was yeah it was it was great she
also uh I've told this a few times but
the great thing uh to bring it back to
my dad uh you know her whatever
catchphrases is by bitch right and uh we
left a message we left a voicemail for
my dad and she said she ended it by
saying bye bitch yeah
then independent of me she got my dad's
information and sent him flowers with a
note that said I'm sorry I called you a
bitch
and my brother and I call him a bitch
all the time we've never apologized you
owe him a lot of flowers yeah we own a
lot of flowers oh that is you made us
root for the Steelers you bitch
um
so anyway uh but the reason your name
came up is one of our writers walked out
and he was wearing a mask and lizzo and
again she'd had a few drinks right she
thought it was Paul Rudd she thought it
was you
um so the writers here today but first I
want to show the first half of the clip
and then we're going to bring out the
writer sethry so here's here's lizzo uh
noticing our writer the first time ah
I'm calm now all right let's bring him
over
all right Paul run hey lizzo I know the
real reason you're breaking up with me
is that you met famous Hollywood actor
Paul Rudd who's now going to take his
mask off and I want you to react to it
in real time
all right so now we're gonna bring out
the writer and we're gonna let you guys
decide was lizzo crazy
all right you know what
not not
as bad as I smell it I owe an apology to
lizzo uh but now uh this is the really
exciting part guys uh because again I
think you're agreeing with lizzo this is
not too far afield until you see the
rest of the face
anyway
there's a lot of other stuff can happen
this better not be this but it better
[Applause]
[Laughter]
there we go let's see both faces there
we go
[Applause]
two snowflakes can't be like we'll be
right back everybody wonderful
so uh yeah give it up
take a moment here to answer what I
imagine is the day drinking FAQ
are you really drinking does the guest
always really drink how drunk do you get
when do you shoot although all the
questions that get answered and asked of
that segment yeah so I do really drink
um a ton we drink so much that I drink
so much sometimes we'd cut out a few
shots because we think it looks bad
I get super drunk and I'm also I hate
hate doing field pieces because I feel
like very out of control like I really
love doing the show in the studio
because I feel like I am in control and
I like that and when I've gone out of
the studio I get very nervous
and but yet after two shots I'm fucking
fine so we realized the more I drink the
more loose it gets what can't alcohol do
I know if there's anything you guys take
home today
but uh and then uh some guests really go
for it Liza really went for it yeah and
then but we did we shot that one on a
Saturday afternoon from noon to two and
uh it was the best and then you're just
drunk until long past dinner that one
was a tough one because uh my I my
family was away which is better yeah but
then I came home and I remember so I got
home and it was around three and I was
thinking you can't go to bed now you've
got to make it till seven yeah and then
I made it till seven and I fell asleep
and I woke up at 8 30 and was awake till
four
not like happy awake that's a that's a
very SNL kind of uh schedule like there
were uh one of my favorite nights so SNL
uh show after party till from one to
four in the morning when we were there I
don't know if this still happens after
after party four to six in the morning
and then sometimes after after after
party from Seven a.m until whatever like
when you leave those parties you are you
walk outside it's bright it's blinding
daylight there are like joggers on the
street and moms pushing kids and parents
pushing kids and strollers uh it's
terrible it's a terrible way to live and
there was one night where we so we were
out until 6 30 in the morning we decided
to go to a diner a bunch of us had to go
to a diner and
um so at seven in the morning we're all
uh pretty drunk still and Seth decides
that he the thing he wants more than
anything in the world is a chicken parm
and he was like I'd like a chicken parm
we all got eggs and whatever and he was
like I'd like a chicken farm and the guy
very reasonably on a Sunday morning it's
at 7am was like we can't make you a
chicken farm and he was just like I
really need a chicken parm and I watched
for 30 minutes as you very politely and
calmly reasoned with this man about why
it was actually it actually could happen
and it was actually the right thing for
him to do
and you were so super polite and really
uh lovely and eventually he went in the
chicken in the kitchen and made you a
goddamn chicken parm and then we left
him like a in the biggest tip that any
waiter has ever gone oh yeah we left in
like a 250 tip on like 40 worth of food
I don't know why that sorry just
occurred to me oh I did day drinking uh
I was one I remember the worst one of
mine was going out uh one of those crazy
late nights and still wearing a suit I'd
worn like a suit to the party and I was
walking out and there was some like five
Borough bike race and so I couldn't
cross Sixth Avenue
because all these bikes were going by
and I was just standing there I'm like
so drunk and these bikes were like
and like every 10th bike was like hey we
cannot wait
foreign
late night there is Tuesday which is
when all the writing gets done and uh so
we're in 30 Rock and we used to so we'd
be there till like six seven in the
morning and then we would go home and
sleep for a little bit and then come
back for the read through and when Rosie
O'Donnell had her talk show uh at 30
Rock very frequently uh on Tuesday you
would walk out and you would see Rosie a
very bright chipper happy Rosita walking
in and I walked out uh once with my
friend Rob Carlock uh who uh later wrote
for friends and and 30 Rock created 30
Rock patina and um we were we were just
dragging our uh our exhausted asses out
of 30 Rock and Rosie and I was walking
by and those of you who uh remember her
show she used to throw Koosh balls at
people that was her thing and uh and she
there was the security guard who checked
her in went like from across she was
walking towards us in security guard
when Rosie and she went like whatever
the guy's name was Jim and she fired a
Koosh ball and it went sideways and it
hit me on the side of the face
and I didn't Flinch or move I just like
kept trudging straight forward like it
just like bounced off like it was like a
ball of Joy flew through the air and
just like just no and and she I think
was like oh sorry and I didn't I
couldn't even talk yeah I just like
groaned or grunted or something
uh it's a bad system it's a bad system
and also kind of amazing uh we're gonna
get to some audience questions in a
second um but the last thing I want to
talk about is documentary now
documentary now
which Seth uh produces
uh was just nominated for a gall dang
Peabody Award
this is a huge deal so tell us about
that idea who you collaborate with all
of the things oh we have a clip do we
need to see another clip right we can
see another all right apparently let's
roll the we got to get this one right
man
it should be black and white
yeah
Alwyn Lewis was the most charismatic
skillful and brutal Craig my spider that
I have ever seen
[Applause]
blood
bars Lewis he owns and Reese Thomas go
back and forth back and forth Krieg mice
or field rock is a sport unique to the
Welsh village it's like Alwyn circus in
which two men enter a sheep pen divided
in half
each fighter has a pile of rocks the
pile they have personally collected from
the surrounding field and during each
three-minute round they take these rocks
and hurl them at one another
with great force
each other
Ali as he was known locally was a folk
hero in Franklin
he'd won the golden Stones as an amateur
and then went pro at 17 and when he
announced he was going to attempt to win
back his title in his hometown of
legolwin unrest
in his first fight in over five years no
less
well it was a national event
[Music]
it's a deeply deeply dumb idea
but
oh thank you for fans of documentaries
when you see one and you go oh my God
they're doing a parody of this genre of
documentary that I love there's no
better feeling it's really bad I mean
it's a very it's a niche show made by
people who love documentaries and uh
love the idea of like lovingly you know
parodying them uh it was born out of
this sketch I wrote with Fred uh called
history of punk at SNL where he was the
only punk rocker who liked Margaret
Thatcher and
uh
written written it should be noted the
week she died and
and then Bill hater uh who came in and
said that would be a show like it would
be so fun to do a show like that because
it would feel like a British show you do
like six episodes seasons
um and uh uh I'm gonna bring it back to
Verna Herzog because this year we did a
Vernon Herzog parody where we parodied
uh Aguirre uh wrath of God and I was
like this can be a tricky thing to
explain to Hertz but I had pictures I'm
like I'm gonna try to do it and so we
had stills from uh documentary and I I
did I Brockton I go so this is we do
this show called documentary now and
immediately realizing I've lost them
yeah and then I go and we're trying we
tried to match aguira and he looks at me
he puts a hand on my hand he goes no one
will ever match that
that was like great
by the way uh uh we got Alexander
Skarsgard played the Vern Herzog but I
had originally said we should just get
Verner hertzog oh my God Berner Hartzog
playing himself in another we're playing
a version of himself in an episode of
documentary and I would have been peaked
documentary now if if he says no I can
get Aubrey to go to his house
she's like do you remember me I'm dead
now
I'm a ghost do you believe in me now
well congratulations on the Peabody
thank you uh nomination nomination
all right so we have your audience
questions um I have not uh screened
these okay I might go it could be fun
Seth it says I'm a card carrying Jackal
love it thank you tackles I wrote the
lyrics to Soviet Happy Days oh oh that's
so exciting Soviet Happy Days was again
I don't quite remember how it started
but uh it was Monday Tuesday these odd
days
Wednesday Thursday also days
uh brief side note same Rob Carlock and
I wrote a schedule to now 100 million
years ago which was um
the premise was it was the show Friends
in an alternate universe where the
Germans had won World War II
and it was just the six of them were all
working very efficiently in like a
Munitions plant
and the the theme song was exactly the
same but it was just the theme song that
jaunty theme song playing over shots of
like wheat Fields just like waving in
the Wind no one liked it
anyway the point here's the question at
what point did you realize Corrections
was a thing that you would build up as
opposed to just a silly bit of online
content signed Trevor Reese uh thank you
Trevor for your work and collaborating
with us it was this really fun once I
realized I was play acting frustrated
and the people online were play acting
that they were yeah and it was this
really cool and then it just it never
got boring and it hasn't yet and I don't
know if it ever will I feel like at some
point I'll it might reach point I'm like
I don't know what else to do but it it
doesn't because it's always based on
what we got wrong it doesn't it doesn't
feel like it's repeating itself do you
have plans for the hundred well I mean
I'm pretty bummed out Eminem said no to
the 50th
and like we didn't hear back from him at
all but I assume like what that meant is
like wait for 100 wait for 100 you must
wait for 100.
Sammy says what makes the perfect or
most enjoyable late night guest is it
comedic chops interesting stories at
Cataract I think it's really fun if
they're willing to go off the Playbook
and with that said somebody there's like
10 different great kinds of guests we
was talking uh to somebody today about
how like Nathan Lane Martin Short have
this old school thing where they write
100 jokes and they come out and they're
just going to tell a hundred jokes and
they're going to go everywhere from a
plus to the worst joke you've ever heard
and they have so much enthusiasm and a
lot of times their roast jokes about you
and them and the audience and so I love
that because that feels like an old
school throwback and sometimes you have
somebody who's just really good at you
know telling a story but the most fun is
when it goes off the rails and you
realize that the guest doesn't care
right yeah that seems key it's like a
person who uh is not just game for
anything but like is happy to let it
like Will Ferrell is the ultimate
version of this yeah Will Ferrell we
were actually just talking about this
before we came out here Will Ferrell
loves when things don't work comedically
like it's his favorite thing he's like
he used to do when he would do sketches
at SNL in dress rehearsal and they would
bomb you would see how he would get so
excited yeah like the silenter it got
the happier he was there was and there
was such a core Integrity to his
performance yeah where he was like oh we
will see this out yes I will sell the
hell out of this as long as it takes to
deadly silence
Courtney says what is the latest night
you can recall having and what did it
entail we almost sort of just answered
that yeah chicken parm yeah I'm trying
to think I mean I I've definitely like
reached the age where there's not many
latest nights uh anymore but uh yeah
yeah you hit it SNL is a specifically is
a is a Young Person's game yes like I I
I left when the I remember I decided to
leave and the year that I left we
started booking musical guests I had
never heard of and I was like yeah right
that's what's supposed to happen
they're not supposed to just book Tom
Petty over and over again to make me
happy I had a there was a ban on our
show that I really liked and I I really
liked the sound and so I was talking to
him and uh and they were younger fellas
and I was like so what did you guys like
listen to Growing Up and they were like
you know The Strokes and I was like oh
oh no oh
Ben Baxter says do you have any pre-show
rituals and if so what are they not
really I feel like SNL was a far more
ritualistic show because it was like
aiming for that one thing every week
whereas I I'm trying to find my way into
a place of like just comfort and so what
I like to do is I go backstage and I say
hi to our guests and the longer you do
the show the more you know them from
previous visits so it's just nice to
like check in you do a fun thing during
the show in a in a sort of a pause in
the production where you go into the
audience and ask answer questions yeah
we it started out of necessity any night
we had a band it takes longer to set up
a band so you go into a q a and then I
just really liked it it also seemed like
a cool thing to do for the audience yeah
and people enjoy it so I'll do like five
minutes of q a uh nights and it's really
fun yeah an in-show ritual Claudia says
I loved your children's book I was going
to mention that in the closing Seth
wrote a children's book uh it's called
you're not scared I'm scared uh
it's and is it New York Times bestseller
yes thank you very much congratulations
so Claudia loves the book uh are there
any plans to write more uh well I'm
gonna do the one you said that you're
announcing yeah yeah The Logical sequel
yeah
and then we're not scared you plural
yeah yeah like everybody's scared and
rightfully so
um I would I would like to do another
one it's so funny like I feel like I did
it chasing my approval of my children
sure and
um pretty quickly even I feel like a lot
of my friends who are even in children's
movies will tell you their kids don't
like to hear their voices like I
remember haters saying like when his
kids saw like Cloudy with a Chance of
Meatball they're like no we don't want
this yeah
um and yeah even for like a book it
happened with my kids they're like okay
Dad yeah
they're like uh this is kid stuff Beyond
not hearing your voice they didn't want
to read your words
it's just like the the jacket photo
uh when will you run for president asks
Bernadette Bernadette never ever
um I also think that's a fake name
um the first one's fake the second one's
real yeah one of them is real yeah
um the I just like well I I won't I mean
it's what a terrible job is the main
thing yeah yeah just a terrible job I uh
I I have thought so often in especially
in the last
few years say since like I don't know
2016 is a rough yeah just estimated when
I've heard this nobody wants a specific
date of like yeah uh of of the um the
number of things if you are a member of
either political party the number of
things you have to do that you don't
want to do just to get to the point
where you are the person who is running
yeah is is incalculable like they they
have to pretend to be other people for a
long time to some degree and then they
have to shift and then they pretend to
be a different other person in the
National time every time you shift
people are like you told us you were
that person yeah yeah I'd say it's a
it's a it's dissociative like I can't
imagine keeping your own I mean you
watch like John McCain I think about a
lot when John McCain was was going for
the net for the he he did things that
you knew he didn't want to do and he was
uniquely bad amongst contemporary
politicians at hiding his disdain for
things like you knew when you saw his
face like he was at Liberty University
and he was miserable yeah he did not
want to be there and he didn't
fundamentally believe in the things that
he was saying but it's like ma this is
what you have to do I can't imagine
taking on a a job or even attempting to
get a job that requires you to
dissociate and compartmentalize to that
degree with that said it would be super
cool to have a president who did
Corrections every week totally
you know what I mean be really cool yeah
you would still do it you're saying yeah
I think that would be I'd be like
obviously made some mistakes in Ukraine
and love to go through them
and it's still just the crew it's like
eight people yeah well I mean that it
would be like White House staff it
wouldn't be a crew but it would be a
crew of stores still on YouTube you
think I think probably YouTube yeah
how is your lobby baby my Lobby baby
just turned five which is nuts
nuts yeah he's five years old uh he's
wonderful the funniest thing is
sometimes we'll be in the park with my
uh five-year-old and my seven-year-old
and people will go which one's Lobby
baby and the seven-year-old loves to
tell people and he goes he's Lobby baby
I'm Hospital baby
and I don't have the heart to tell them
like that's the common one nobody cares
like that he's the famous one you're
like are you still in the same building
you are in the same building I'm so
bummed because this year I had my wife
lying on the floor and had Axel get
between her legs and took a picture when
he turned five and I'm like we should
have done that every year oh yeah you
know what I mean like because it's the
same that's the height on the wall
that's your version of the height on the
wall but it is the best thing in the
world because people I mean there is a
special relationship with him and
everybody in that building because he
was born I would imagine did I ever tell
you a story about how alpha my wife is
which is uh my wife gave birth in the
library building and then on the way to
the hospital because you still gotta go
to the hospital especially because you
called 9-1-1 and they show up and you
can't be like we're good
so we're in the hospital and my wife uh
says oh right the head of the co-op
board and say will pay to replace the
carpet
because I I don't like it like she and
like at the design level
my wife had already not liked it and
then because she had a baby on it she
saw a window
to replace it we're in the ambulance
and I'm like okay so I write them and
I'm like hey crazy thing just happened
you know we uh you might hear soon and
then the next day they wrote exactly
what they should have written which was
like oh my God no word don't worry about
it we're so happy for you guys and so
then it's the next day we're in the
hospital and like say like hey did you
write them I'm like I did and she's like
what did they say and I was like they
said they'll take care of it and then
she said how did you say it
I okay
I want to proffer a theory yeah she
always hated that rug she did months
before she tried to get rid of it it
didn't work right she thought to herself
you know what I bet would get rid of the
rug
you know what
now you mention it I think her water
broke a long time before I think so too
and she was like and then she waited
until she knew she timed her
contractions yeah
and then I'm the sucker who I had to
call an Uber I'm like it hurt my rating
you know
you know what it's like when you go out
and tell an Uber like hey we don't
actually don't need you yeah can't do
that to the ambulance can do it
who has been someone you worked with and
keep before I finish this keep in mind
I'm right here I'm very excited
where you felt you learned the most
about yourself
well that's an interesting question I
learned the most about myself I will say
we're both very lucky to I think when
you work with people of exceptional
Talent which is what happens at SNL and
you have to put your work up in front of
them at an early stage at that read
through table it is
um
that fear of embarrassing yourself in
front of great people is so important
because you just your drive to not
embarrass yourself yeah makes you so
much better and then I think at some
point you you when you actually become
good is when you stop worrying about
embarrassing yourself and then you just
start aiming for the next level I think
there's something there's a difference
though between learning something about
yourself creatively and learning
something by yourself like as a person
right I think Mike Shoemaker your
producer used to be the produced senior
producer at SNL is uniquely good at
teaching you about yourself as you
relate to the job like as a human being
yes like that's that is his his sort of
super skill was like he was half
producer half therapist essentially for
everybody who worked at SNL and it's
like when you had a problem that about
the way that you related to the job that
you didn't know how to solve or how to
even articulate you went to my Shoemaker
and he explained here's what's going on
yeah and that that so he'd be my answer
in all likelihood but I but creatively
yeah like working for Adam McKay at
McKay was the head writer of SNL and
Tina Fey with the head writers when I
first started there and my thought all
the time was please let me someday do
something they like yeah like that's all
I wanted in the world uh never achieved
it no I uh but you that being around
Talent like extraordinary Talent
especially at a formative age is the
thing Shoemaker was is very much that
and also I think the the thing about
being a person one thing he would always
say is uh tempers sometimes ran hot at
SNL and you'd be really mad at someone
maybe a fellow writer maybe a fellow
cast member and I remember at times
being like here's what I'm gonna go tell
him and always go it's a long life
and I promised that 10 years from now
the people you work here with are going
to be like family yeah and uh don't like
burn it down for some sketch that none
of you are going to remember and that
was really really good advice he also
did this thing where someone would go
like this is ridiculous the way this
thing happened and blah blah blah and
you would go and yell and scream and he
would go like here's what's happening
you're thinking you might want to leave
the show and because you think you might
want to leave the show you're scared
about what's next and because you're
um you're scared you're manufacturing an
argument a problem that you have with
the show that doesn't really exist or it
exists for everybody in equal measure
and it's not unique to you because you
want to feel better about the decision
to leave and you'd be like
fuck that's totally what's happening and
then you would just calm down and go
back to your job the one that I still uh
we still laugh about is I think it was
my maybe my second year on the show and
uh it was before I had any you know uh
role at the show on the writer side so
it was just a cast member I wrote
sketches and I remember you know you
read through you'd write a sketch and
then uh the power Brokers would go into
room and they'd come out and then you
picks would be out it was like finding
out if you made the school play it was
literally like posted on the wall and
everything and a sketch I'd written that
I thought had played well didn't get in
and then I went like like moped on over
Charlie Brown into shoemaker's office
and like lied down on his couch he's
like are you okay and I was like yeah
it's just I really wanted to do that one
and instead of being sympathetic he just
went oh you really wanted to
oh well let me let me call Lauren maybe
he hasn't left yet
oh if you really want and I was like all
right I get it I get your points fine
yes
Robin C
asks what or who is your favorite or
most memorable guest or interview
um
you know I think the fact that Letterman
was on the show for the 40th anniversary
of the of the latest very big deal and
also new in my bones the last thing
David Letterman wants is for you to be
like you meant so much to me you're a
legend everything you'd want to say if
you but he's incapable of receiving that
in a comfortable way so I knew that the
only way it would be enjoyable for him
and then probably more enjoyable for
everybody is if I just actually did what
you're supposed to do and so it uh you
try to like stay Within Myself and be
just a human being because that's what
he always liked I mean that's why he
actually had regular you know
non-celebrities on the show all the time
right and uh and so the fact that that
like it was terrifying
and yet it was executed well enough that
I was proud of it was he again we're
roughly the same age was he your guy he
was my guy too yeah so that was and it
was um it was just a trip to have your
and it was also a really fun show
because we did a joke Seth can't tell
first in the First Act and when he came
out he was very complimentary about that
and uh did he say uh lesbian black lady
like Henry Winkler he was like nobody
was like I think we should cancel Henry
Winkler yeah
Jake says where did Frisbee's name come
from your dog frisbee yeah frisbee we
just saw I just laid eyes on her and
said frisbee I just kind of knew she
looked like a Frisbee and I've been born
out to be cracked she has maybe the best
running bit on your shows how much
Sandberg hates frisbee yeah but also
maybe not a bit I think that deserves a
plus
um frisbee hates uh sorry Anthony hates
frisbee so much and then this time he
was on the show and he's like he looks
like a rat and I was like Frisbee's a
she he's like what
just like hating on a dog didn't even do
the basic work of you wait I'm sorry you
mean Andy Samberg didn't totally
understand something
do you know that he did on the holiday
card what's that you the holiday card
bit no I we sent him a holiday card uh
our dog frisbee was on the holiday card
with the kids he scratched out her face
and mailed it back
like a serial killer
oh his commitment is a really good bet
Lacey asks was there a moment you
remember in particular that made you
decide you wanted to be an Entertainer
I
definitely saw my college improv troop
my new student week and thought that
looks like the most fun thing I've ever
seen and then I didn't get into that
troop I auditioned every year I didn't
get into my senior year whoa really it
was eight it was eight people and uh it
was there were guys and gals a year
older than me and they were like the and
they were great but they were that group
for and then I got into Northwestern
University Northwestern University
Evanston Illinois and then I got in my
senior year and I remember doing a show
in front of you know whatever it was
like a you know it was a big room and it
was a there was a good improv trip and I
just remember being like Oh I want to do
this until they told me to stop but that
was I think that is a powerful moment in
any writer's life or performer's life is
like Samberg talks about this speaking
of Samberg he talks about being like
three years old in the bathtub and like
making his mom laugh and just like the
endorphins just lit up and he was just
like whatever this whatever I'm doing I
want to do this forever like there is
always a formative moment in everyone's
life where like the laughter becomes the
thing that is Meaningful yeah we're like
oh I think this is a drug that won't
kill me
Matt says what is your favorite TV show
right now ooh I think succession is my
favorite TV show right now yeah tough to
beat tough to beat it's a tough to be
right now and um yeah it's also it's a
very I like when there's a show my wife
and I like equally it's the best um it
is I remind I mean all the TV I watched
as a kid was with everybody and I feel
like you don't do that in the same way
like we would my family and would all
watch TV together
um let me ask you this my wife is a
comedy writer we the two of us almost
never watch comedies do you do you are
you a more do you watch more dramas with
your wife ah thousand percent yeah yeah
yeah it's like the last thing in the
world you want is to watch a comedy yeah
I would say a comedy the only comedy
that I well not the only but like I
think you should leave with Tim Robinson
like that
yeah it's just like it's the purest
white hot Joy machine yeah
um but it's it's almost like yeah if you
can it I also like when I'm watching a
comedy I I'm either like jealous that
somebody can figure out so well or I can
sort of see the seams whereas like
watching a drama is just a you know
what's in an exception to this rule is
the show The Great I don't know if
anybody watches the show they're great
um the great I think is me is one of the
best shows on TV and it's a comedy and a
drama but also it like invented a new
tone that did yeah before like he found
a new tone somehow it's really I do feel
like that's a fascinating thing that's
happening TV right now is it when people
do that because I feel like a lot of
people in a great way are trying to aim
for that where it's not like
algorithmically what's worked yeah I
know and it's wonderful when it works um
what is it like to rework a topical
sketch if new information breaks after
it's selected and before you tape it we
kind of cover yeah we kind of got that
it happens less than you'd think and and
we try to Savvy it without trying to get
two of our skis and guessing what the
story is what would you say if you knew
your little league coach and high school
classmate were in the audience signed
Franklin and Jason
wellgul I can't read it is that true
where are you guys
hey were you really a literally coach in
in New Hampshire
all right
I should have started
yeah uh uh my dad was the Umpire uh
lovely to see you guys yeah my dad was a
little League umpire because you
probably don't know says that is the
least surprising statement that you've
ever made
um and he's been literally the reason he
told me he wanted to be an Umpire
instead of a literally coach is you
could yell at the kids
I think what the party left out is also
last year when I was a coach I yelled at
a kid and they told me I can't be a
coach anymore
um again remember it's Mike Lindell your
picture picture yeah who's like the most
loving man in the world who yells more
yeah um uh this is uh this made me think
this I can't believe it's an actual uh
uh I mean it blows my mind but I uh do
you remember did you go to West
okay do you remember uh uh coach Levine
the football coach so uh coach Levine
had a son Andy Levine that I was friends
with and then I decided junior year of
high school that I was going to play
football which is too late to decide
but I was like I'm gonna play football
this year and I went to coach Levine who
I'd known he was my friend's dad uh and
I was like I want to play football he's
like don't play football and I was like
I want to play he's like look you're
never going to play uh just because we
have other guys who've been here and I
got to start you and JV and it's gonna
be a waste your time and I'm like I
really want to play football I had my
hard set on and so I did the whole like
uh summer like went to practice every
day for like like played with the uh
those guys and then uh the last day of
uh summer practices he called me into
his office and he was like I'm gonna cut
you from the football team no one had
ever been cut from the football team
and I was like I can't believe you're
cutting me from the football team he's
like here's the thing I just think this
is a waste of your time and I just feel
like you have better things to do and I
had so much resentment about that for a
really long time because I was deeply
embarrassed that I got cut from the
football team and like they like guys
that I was friends with would say you
know you're the only guy
I'd like to say weren't even being mean
it was just like a fascinating piece of
trivia
um anyway then years later I'm an SNL
and I went back to speak in my high
school and Coach Levine had become a
guidance counselor and I was walking
down the hallway and I saw him come the
other way and he went I told you
and I was like oh right and he gave me
the biggest hug and I was like yeah what
the fuck I wasn't supposed to play
football
that's amazing a couple of nights thanks
for coming out guys
Katie a couple more questions Katie says
if you could interview one person living
or dead who would it be I think Benjamin
Franklin right I feel like has a like
real great Insight on he would have good
stories
he would be the Martin short version he
would have jokes he would have stuff
prepared and I think he liked I think he
would tell like uh the real story yeah
yeah he also had syphilis so he'd
probably say a lot of crazy yeah
like untreated syphilis ravaging his
brain that would be interesting and I
think he'd like tell I think he'd like
lie like fucking crazy yeah I think also
the fun thing if you bring back a dead
person to be on a talk show if you let
them know everybody you know is dead and
not coming back
so just go go crazy
uh that was our final question is 9 p.m
uh can I say something real quick please
I want to say something uh uh first of
all thank you for doing this you're
quite welcome
Mike
uh Mike had been on SNL for a few years
before I got there uh you were very much
my first friend I ever made on that show
it was the scariest time of my life I
can't even imagine what it would have
been like uh without having you there
and so it's like amazing to be here with
you talking about everything now thank
you buddy that's very kind of you
one of the
one of the best days I had at SNL was
the day that I found out that Seth was a
Boston Red Sox fan
and one of the worst days was two
minutes later when I found out he was
not a New England Patriots fan but like
the Pittsburgh Steelers yeah
um but we became very fast friends
um we played a lot of Madden football
and we need Xbox in my office
um my life was made immeasurably better
at us know when you showed up and the
there's a hallway where they put up
sketches like they take still photos of
sketch and one in the hallway and I
remember thinking it's gonna be so
exciting the first time I'm in a sketch
that makes the hallway and you know what
the first time I was in the hallway I
don't hot air balloon theater hot air
balloon uh was it air balloon Mystery
Theater hotter balloon Mystery Theater
is a sketch Mike wrote and it was a
murder took place on a hot air balloon
it was it was just it was a Sherlock
Holmes situation
so it was I wrote it for someone I
remember who and the premise was a
murder it happened in a hot air balloon
and so there was a lot of just like the
Sherlock Holmes guy going like the
killer had ample time to get from this
part part of the basket to this part of
the basket and I I was so happy with it
and it did pretty well and then it
didn't get chosen and I resubmitted it a
little while later and it and it did
really well again and it didn't get
chosen and then Ian McKellen hosted and
I was like if Ian McAllen can't play
Sherlock Holmes it'll never happen and
he he did it and it killed and it got on
the show and you were in it a polar
resident and I was so happy you felt
like oh my God this thing that I truly
love finally got on the show and then it
played to like very middling yes but it
was like one again it's one of those
sketches that it because exactly it's
that kind of thing you just want to
write a sketch where when you tell
people about it years later it gets that
reaction whatever and also don't don't
watch it don't watch it enjoy this but I
will say the thing I remember the best
is there's a chase scene at the end yeah
and so
just picture like eight people like just
like rotating yeah like kind of getting
in each other's way and yeah and I think
I had like it was my dream because I had
like big mutton and I think I attacked
like this it was some very you did a
James Mason I was doing it you were
doing James Mason yeah um the my
favorite part of it subtly and again
please don't watch it it's like a c plus
yeah but my favorite part is at the end
he grabs the Killer and then two British
Bobbies pop up from nowhere out of the
basket and they're like you're a top to
jail with you like which again was so
fun to know that whole sketch they were
in the past they were in the best yeah
uh and are you because you mentioned Red
Sox fans we um I I think about this all
the time because I've stayed at the Four
Seasons in Boston since but we were
going to a game and we were talking
about uh where should we stay and I
remember Mike said you know what we're
doing great like let's not stay in a
shitty hotel let's say at the Four
Seasons I'm like let's stay at the Four
Seasons and then the thing I always
remember is we did but we shared a room
yeah
it was two twin beds in like like a 250
square foot room yeah and so we spent
all this money and then we like
literally like just were in a Jason twin
beds talking about baseball before he
fell asleep
we really had it figured out uh Late
Night with Seth Meyers airs weeknights
at 12 37 a.m the very normal time that's
perfect on NBC Corrections is on The
Late Night YouTube channel Seth also I
will mention again has a New York Times
best-selling book it's called no one
scared Everybody's scared some something
something like that yeah it's that's the
German version it got translated it got
translated poorly yeah uh unlike uh
Donald Trump Jr one of the most talented
people in the world Seth Meyers thank
you very much Mike sir thank you
everybody
thank you
[Music]